look at the biggest accomplishments the
setbacks and the challenges during
president joe biden's first year in
office today is the anniversary and the
president gave himself high marks at his
news conference yesterday afternoon
saying he quote
probably outperformed what anybody
thought would happen now one year ago
today mr biden was sworn in after a very
contentious election that divided the
country and amid a pandemic that has now
dominated american life and continues to
do so unfortunately and o'keeffe shows
us all that has happened over the last
365 days
my whole soul is in this
bringing america together
uniting our people during his first
speech as commander-in-chief president
biden promised to tackle the nation's
many challenges
but unity quickly proved hard to find
racial justice protests continued
while teachers parents and students
bristled plans to keep schools safe from
the coronavirus the new administration
ramped up vaccine distribution and
passed trillions of dollars in financial
relief we're closer than ever to
declaring our independence from this
deadly virus over the summer the
pandemic took a temporary back seat to
foreign policy as a controversial
decision to end america's involvement in
afghanistan sparked chaos i was not
going to extend this forever war and i
was not extending a forever exit here we
go the administration succeeded in
enacting major infrastructure
legislation let's believe in
possibilities let's believe in one
another but plans for an ambitious
spending bill remained stalled as fall
turned to winter supply chain
disruptions and inflation and consumer
prices soaring and a new covet variant
sparked long lines at testing and
vaccination sites once again we have to
do more we have to do better and we will
still the president kicked off the new
year pushing for voting reform and
blasting his predecessor's supporters
they want chaos to reign
we want the people to rule and unity in
congress like in much of the country
continues to remain elusive for cbs
mornings i'm ed o'keefe at the white
house
for more on what happened and what it
means we are joined now by cbs news
political contributor and democratic
strategist joel payne and steve hayes he
is co-founder ceo and editor of the
dispatch gentlemen good morning to both
of you uh that was a nearly two-hour
long press conference yesterday there
were questions from conservative outlets
liberal outlets middle of the road
outlets foreign language outlets
international outlets if it went any
longer dogs and children were going to
be asking questions so if you could joel
off the top help us take away kind of
the headline what was the big message
that you got from those two hours
well i think some of the message was
non-verbal which is i'm the president i
can stand and take the heat and i've got
the endurance to do the job and i think
that's part of what his team wanted to
do they wanted to reflect that you have
an engaged president you have a
president that is focused on the job at
hand
he did make some news for his team
unfortunately they had to do some
cleanup afterwards related to
issues in russia
he made some comments about
potentially russia invading the ukraine
which his team again had to clean up
afterwards and i think he also made news
around the buildback better agenda
revealing that that is going to have to
be broken up into multiple pieces of
legislation so you know press
conferences like that they they really
don't move the needle i think that they
more reflect the direction and i think
the direction of this president is to
attempt to reset as we look at the
beginning of 2022. yeah steve
the president in his inaugural address
uh promised to be a unifier for the
country he campaigned that way as well
uh unfortunately for the administration
people seem to be unifying around
disapproval at the moment do you think
that press conference changed the
narrative in any way
i don't i mean i agree with joel that
you know if endurance was one of the
measuring sticks he did well i mean i
think people were surprised that he was
able to stand up there for two hours and
answer questions but i think he raised
as many questions as he answered in in
several different ways i mean if you
talk about look at the his comment about
a minor incursion by the russians into
ukraine
you saw immediate reaction from overseas
particularly in kiev where officials
said boy that seems like a green light
for vladimir putin you also had the
president's comments on
uh the possibility of an illegitimate
election in 2022 when he was asked a
question about whether if these voting
reforms that have been debated in
congress don't pass that would
contribute to the illegitimacy of the
2022 elections i think the right answer
would be to reaffirm
the strength of our electoral system
while you know expressing disappointment
that that the the reforms were unlikely
to pass instead he said yeah it's
possible that the 2022 elections could
be illegitimate which i think is not
what we need whether you're a republican
or a democrat a liberal or conservative
i know so steve how is that helpful and
doesn't that set up a tit-for-tat
dynamic that i think is very troubling
on many issues
yeah i mean i think it's worrisome i
mean look if you're a conservative and
you've got questions or problems with
the way that donald trump conducted
himself in in the aftermath of the 2020
election lying about whether the
election was stolen trying to remain in
office what his supporters have been
doing in states and localities across
the country
um to to basically put themselves in a
position where they could muscle through
uh an illegitimate election the last
thing you wanted to hear was to hear
from president biden that there are
questions about the legitimacy of the
elections you needed the president to
say no we've got the best electoral
system in the world
the safest the most secure and one thing
we don't need to worry about even if i'm
frustrated that republicans aren't
supporting me on these voting reforms
the one thing that we can be sure of is
that the elections will be legitimate
joel you mentioned it briefly the
president said that he is considering
breaking up the build back better plan
is it as simple as just giving in and
trying to pass it in chunks as you said
well here's the thing i mean part of
that would be you'd still need to get 60
votes for some of that now there are
parts of that agenda that if you maybe
offered up piecemeal you could maybe get
to that 60 vote threshold you got folks
like senator romney who might support
parts of that agenda you've got other
moderates in that republican caucus who
might support part of that agenda and i
think for probably some of the
president's allies they're looking
forward to an opportunity for him again
to reset and to focus more on a unity
message getting back to the messages of
the bipartisan infrastructure bill right
bipartisan bringing republicans along on
the other hand for a lot of democrats
you've got a lot of frustration that
some of the core progressive agenda
items voting rights reform um some of
the more um you know expansive parts of
the build back better agenda are
probably not going to get passed in this
cycle of congress
but joel the two big parts of buildback
better that the president cares about a
lot he said are free community college
so the the country guaranteeing an
education two years beyond primary
school uh and also a child tax credit
which can lift millions of kids out of a
hunger uh if those are broken off and
passed does that change the narrative
for the midterms i mean it looks like
they're going to lose at the moment
could could could those bills those
separate pieces change that
well democrats have to decide whether or
not they want to tell a positive story
about this presidency if you look on one
hand you could say you passed a major
infrastructure bill you already passed
the big covet relief bill which had some
child care tax credit in it last year
and you've got a chance to pass a little
bit more going into 2022 and that's
something you could sell to voters as
you look at the midterm elections you
could you could tell the story like that
you could also tell the story in a way
to say we're not getting as much as we
want and i think what the president is
probably trying to do among many things
bringing the country together is also
bucking up his party and getting his
party to feel good about the work that
they've done over the last 13 months and
so i think part of the president's job
is psychological here to get his party
on board
right kane and hayes a political
consultancy you guys could work together
there's a little ring to that pain and
haze i like that there we go all right
we appreciate you guys thank you so much